[Music]
bague Markel is redefining work of
fashion and at a hefty price
1 million dollars as the day she gave
Prince Harry's fiance that million
dollar figure comes from adding up the
pieces of her dresses coats and
accessories like hats shoes bags and
jewelry but who's paying for it it's a
surprise it does fall now that she is
married into the royal family to the
Prince of Wales to cover the cost of her
working Royal wardrobe the cost of her
wedding ensemble was over four hundred
and forty thousand dollars and her
reception outfit more than one hundred
fifty-seven thousand it may be that
Megan contributed but certainly some of
the cost for either of those wedding
dresses or Pat both of those wedding
dresses I believe was also picked up by
the palace Prince Charles has been
footing the bill for her working
wardrobes at the announcement of his
son's engagement so is the cost worth it
I think most people would argue that it
is megan is now an ambassador for the
royal family look at the publicity that
she is brought in the run-up to the
wedding I'd argue that it's worth every
penny since becoming a member of the
royal family we've noticed Megan wearing
a lot of pink
I think it's Megan's way of choosing a
color but not wanting to upstage anyone
and it suits her a swords report that
the Duchess has been taking secret
meetings with various charities just
like Princess Diana did and she will
soon announce which one she will
officially support Megan will need lots
of clothes which he hits the road with
upcoming trips to Ireland Australia and
New Zealand with Harry so would Megan
consider recycling an outfit like her
sister-in-law Kate dies I'm quite sure
that we will see Megan step out in
outfits that she's worn before you know
when you're buying that sort of Kuchar
with those sorts of price tags it would
be criminal to not rewear them
[Music]
[Applause]